hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to si.com not net no
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see Django Unchained so what are you
and I hang out Ryan's consensus Django
Unchained is the reason movies are made
jingo unchanged the reason movies are
made the material written for every cast
member is great in this movie but I must
say the actors instantaneously elevate
the already terrific material I agree
with you Jerry's consensus Django
Unchained is the reason movies aren't
mad Django Unchained recent movies are
made reason to see number one Jamie Foxx
we're all thinking the same thing is
that Jamie Foxx is real penis I'm not
gonna let you I was thinking about it
Jamie Foxx is a perfect it's great how
this movie starts off or he's like this
broken timid slave then arcs into a
complete badass which is one hundred
percent believable by the way yeah he
anchors everything with this this cool
intensity a lot of the other characters
are much more flashy than Jamie Foxx's
so he occasionally gets outshined but
the performance of Django is much more
subtle than everyone else's as it should
be you see I wouldn't even say he was
outshine partly because you know he has
to lay low in these situations that he
has to sort of silently observed you
know even one of the characters are
driving the scenes he doesn't fade into
the background you could always feel the
intensity of what he's feeling and you
know you can feel the situation at hand
sort of emanating off of him he's always
a strong present this dude just gets
cooler as the movie progresses till the
very last frame which is of him like
being so cool
you're interested in this character
right from the get-go and you're within
the whole way there's also an innocence
to his performance which makes him that
much more likeable and it makes his
relationship with christoph waltz all
the more enjoyable reason to see number
two Christoph Waltz genius is the word
for Christoph Waltz yes I liked him more
on this and I did an inglorious basterds
because he has that same level of
freedom to his performance but this time
he's playing the protagonist it is
gratifying because like he's so good at
playing a deliciously evil guy mm-hmm
and now the sea can put all that
charisma into you know a really likeable
guy that is ok to think he has a lot of
fun he's badass he's hilarious he's
waiting at the same time it's very
caring the dude kills with practically
no regret whoever he has to kill but at
the same time he's a compassionate doc
the buddy aspect between Christophe
Alton and Jamie Foxx is just so fun to
watch you know like I could watch hours
of Django and Schultz just hanging out
hood and you know it's so much fun to
watch their relationship grow from you
know a small agreement into a
partnership into a true friendship you
know he helps Django find his legs to
stand on and once he does it really
feels like they're equals reason to see
number three Leonardo DiCaprio DiCaprio
comes in late into this movie but
regardless of his late arrival which by
the way nothing before him is boring at
all you kind of forget that he's one of
the stars of this movie but anyway he
comes in late but it's for some reason
at the right time the they're definitely
moments work where he's pretty scary
he's a sociopathic lunatic who like
thinks he's very sophisticated I love
him as the villain because you can see
the charm you can see how he persuades
his people you can feel his dark
passionate emotions and you totally
believe that back then man like him
existed which makes them that much
scarier it's weird cuz he's kind of a
punk but he's also got this high-class
pneus but in the end it's not even like
he's actually fully in control so it's a
it's a fascinating character to look at
he's just so deliciously slimy he's a
villain you love to watch for the same
breath you don't want him to succeed and
you can't wait to see him get his ass
kicked yeah it's like he deserves a good
ass kicking that's a hard line to bally
it's great to see an actor who usually
plays leading men turn into a terrifying
but more importantly a believable
building I'm just so happy that this guy
is fictional without a real person yeah
I mean or not we're not used to seeing
him play such ugly character fits he
always feels dangerous and like he could
snap at any second like you never feel
quite comfortable around him even though
he's got the all the southern Chung you
know mmm southern China reason to see
number for Kerry Washington she is
beautiful I bought her as this slave who
can speak German just that fear she
admits in the situations that she's put
and makes her that much more believable
makes the whole story that much more
believable parole isn't huge but it is
important she is a good job with what
she's given she really sells these
horrible situations that she keeps
getting put in you know at the hands of
these slave drivers well they pull her
out of that hot box man she can't help
but cringe she's put in a lot of
situations where you can't help but
cringe a little bit she's feels so
goddamn sorry for her I feel like a bad
person retro reason to see number five
samuel l jackson the old slave who
betrayed his own people yeah man
Tom you know he's a pretty scary Samuel
Jackson good or bad is always scary
reasons not to see you Samuel Jackson in
first in person no he will yell at you
he's another character who comes in late
into the film but yet again just at the
right time with just the right amount of
screen time he's one of those characters
who has this sort of you know facade but
you get the sense there's something
really dangerous about him too and it's
a comfortable watch because you know you
become afraid of him as well it's not
just the main credited actors that are
solid every one of the cast members in
this film perfectly solid